Hello, TikTok.
This is your HR lady coming to you.
We are at the beginning of Black History Month,
so this is why I decided to do the video on
Black and White,
because I want to talk about diversity.
Diversity is so much bigger than race.
Race is extremely important when it comes to diversity.
So is education.
So is where I grew up.
So is religion.
All of those things will have a play
in a way that one person thinks over another.
If I went to school or if I didn't go to school,
my thought process may be different.
My religious beliefs,
All of that plays a role in
when you're thinking about a diverse workforce.
And you don't want people who all think the same.
Another thing,
leaders, please make sure you know this.
You cannot say you have a diverse workforce
if your leadership team
does not reflect the community in which you serve.
Think about that.